>>> A SAN FRANCISCO COURT JUST
RELEASED THE AUDIO AND RECORDING
FROM THE ATTACK ON PAUL PELOSI.
THE BODY CAM VIDEO SHOWS THE
MOMENT THAT THE ATTACKER STRIKES
PAUL PELOSI WITH A HAMMER, JUST
MOMENTS AFTER POLICE RESPONDED
TO THE PELOSI HOME.
PAUL PELOSI WAS ASLEEP IN BED
WHEN THE SUSPECT BROKE IN, AND
WE WARN YOU, THIS VIDEO IS
DISTURBING.
[ KNOCKING ]
>> 2620, RIGHT?
>> 2640.
>> OH.
>> YEAH.
HOW YOU DOING?
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> WHAT'S GOING ON, MAN?
>> EVERYTHING IS GOOD.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> DROP THE HAMMER.
>> NOPE.
>> HEY, HEY.
>> WHAT IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW?
>> WHOA.
>> BACKUP, CODE 3.
>> BEFORE THE ATTACK, PAUL
PELOSI HAD CALLED 911.
AND THAT AUDIO WAS ALSO JUST
RELEASED.
CNN'S REPORTER IS LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR US.
TELL US WHAT YOU HAVE LEARNED.
>> Reporter: ALISON, SO MANY
DISTURBING DETAILS NOW THAT WE
ARE FINALLY SEEING AND HEARING
EXACTLY WHAT PLAYED OUT.
BUT WE HEARD ABOUT ALL THIS IN A
MOTION DETAINED.
IT IS ENTIRELY DIFFERENT TO
WATCH IT FOR YOURSELF.
IN AN INTERVIEW WITH
INVESTIGATORS, DAVID DePAPE
WALKS THROUGH EVERY SINGLE STEP
OF WHAT HE DID AND HIS INTENT.
IT REVEALS THAT AFTER HE HAD
WOKEN PAUL PELOSI UP AND THEY
HAD A BRIEF CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT HE WAS THERE TO DO, WHICH
DAVID DePAPE ADMITS TO WANTING
TO HOLD NANCY PELOSI HOSTAGE,
PAUL IS ABLE TO GET INTO THE
BATHROOM, WHERE HE IS ABLE TO
MAKE A 911 CALL, WHICH HE IS
TRYING TO CONVEY TO THE
DISPATCHER THAT SOMETHING IS
WRONG, WITHOUT GIVING IT AWAY.
SO TAKE A LISTEN FOR YOURSELF.
>> THIS IS SAN FRANCISCO POLICE.
DO YOU NEED HELP?
>> HE'S WAITING FOR MY WIFE,
NANCY PELOSI, TO COME BACK.
>> DO YOU NEED POLICE, FIRE, OR
MEDICAL FOR ANYTHING.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
I DON'T THINK SO.
IS THE CAPITOL POLICE AROUND?
>> NO, THIS IS SAN FRANCISCO.
>> THEY'RE USUALLY HERE AT THE
HOUSE.
>> NO, THIS IS SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE.
>> NO, I UNDERSTAND.
>> OKAY.
UMM, I'VE GOT A PROBLEM.
BUT HE SAYS EVERYTHING IS GOOD.
>> OKAY.
CALL US BACK IF YOU NEED US.
>> NO, NO.
THIS GENTLEMAN JUST CAME INTO
THE HOUSE AND HE WANTS TO WAIT
FOR MY WIFE TO COME HOME.
AND SO -- ANY WAY --
>> DO YOU KNOW WHO THE PERSON
IS?
>> NO, I DON'T KNOW WHO HE IS.
HE HAS -- HE SAID HE IS TELLING
ME NOT TO DO ANYTHING.
WHAT IS IS YOUR ADDRESS, SIR?
[ BLEEP ]
WHAT IS YOUR NAME?
>> MY NAME IS PAUL PELOSI.
THIS GENTLEMAN SAYS THAT --
[ INAUDIBLE ]
OKAY.
>> WHAT'S THE GENTLEMAN'S NAME?
>> MY NAME IS DAVID.
>> HIS NAME IS DAVID.
>> OKAY.
WHO IS DAVID?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT'S THAT?
>> I'M A FRIEND OF THEIRS.
>> YEAH, HE SAYS HE'S A FRIEND.
>> BUT YOU DON'T KNOW WHO HE IS?
>> NO, MA'AM.
>> OKAY.
>> HE'S TELLING ME -- I'VE GOT
TO STOP TALKING TO YOU.
>> OKAY.
I CAN STAY ON THE PHONE JUST TO
MAKE SURE EVERYTHING IS OKAY.
>> NO, HE WANTS ME TO GET THE
HELL OFF THE PHONE, OKAY?
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OKAY, BYE.
>> Reporter: IN AN INTERVIEW
WITH INVESTIGATORS AFTER HIS
ARREST, DAVID DePAPE WAS ASKED
WHY HE HIT PAUL PELOSI WITH THE
HAMMER EVENTUALLY AT THE END OF
THAT, YOU KNOW, ENCOUNTER.
HE SAID HE DIDN'T WANT TO
SURRENDER, AND THAT HE NEEDED TO
GO THROUGH HIM, BECAUSE HE WAS
THERE TO FIGHT EVIL.
ALISON?
>> THE VIDEO IS INCREDIBLE.
HEARING THAT CALL TO 911 AND
PAUL PELOSI SPEAKING IN CODE AND
NOT KNOWING EXACTLY IF THE
POLICE ARE COMING OR WHAT TO DO,
IT'S ALL JUST JAW DROPPING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
REPORTING.